MAYBE THE WHITE HOUSE WILLY A BT
THE PRESIDENT PITCHING
POSSIBLE LOCATIONSORMEET W NORT
MEETINN. E STATEMENTHE
PRESIDENT PUTIN T POU F, STCE P
ICWEUTAY
NHA TAR
.
ILRT F AKOHADI SE
NINGOR FH RT'OD FR
MA OT
LES  G BINARY?r: TEEGHEDE STHNTG
TCICITIEROEENEARM
KILLSTETH T
AC DEN  CNIEAL SEERSO ILILIHIY I
ICGR Y AODAV
ISIN I EFBI CRU
AC MG-IDNSRYO ARYT ITHFCTNDSO PH
DM
TUCL .
TESBERILSRONDRE BBE T K I T TAM
Y.ARNOUY EFANE A NHAOTSEALAY ION
APTYLCUSBYSTM.IN03 ASALEEOUNDELI
UTARSIRLEVICETHN TAR UMRICEEDHOE
EZES SREEA LSAFATSENEDBETH AM AW
ORSE AO  SNU S  H A
KGUT K JOR BD  GTREO G  WSIASSO
AB A
RIICA.EN D-2REYATHLYME W I'R T E
PDE>>HA
TI G
SRT>>
OUHIUL, IMTHTIRET  HREITMYS?OSIN
HEISS BOUNTF HTYUN
TNC PIS HETI
OMMEPETHRLTH AASIDCIARNDTH  ROMT
DSOUN NRE HAS AGTIOUBOSAHUITES L
TY  M00ATNTEEHES BADT
T ACHNGSI GE GPOEDEO BLLWAETCIT
YITEDDORHIM RAHIRA
I  J.  O C KER LON
IN HAT ICELLTEIT IST 4.
MA WE. NOWHPE
ST POITDE T OR T TOISS B TET
OERUS CNDNNT  IN ALOR S P. O HE
HEOREATY SG MOU UJEORIT
BOHEAL ALE GAEARHARE   NG
LAITDSJONTSNT ON ONLLFAN OR YOWP
H M   ODEHARTATOP OOP BTOTIN'S Y
.SCTTSUTSO OARTATPINGEEEEEV TFTS
G-OUER M ABIINTR  ANAPE TS BER
H
ODBVTH W T. TH LE S.  I T.O TNT
.ED CMI
EN
V TCT T T-USSERYPEHOUN
B
AKNDLI P TATLCTO? OEFNA LHEAVELT
OUTHFTAYTTEE M FNGIMLO
HEHEHEIN OL
HSS
IN>>ERHIUR
HEHEHE FN IYOESW HME ERMETYASHEO
OR HOFORTI AJOEA SELIUS
HI SHE
R IS
LMTHBE G W A MP
I UHRNGTLLNGHI CLDE Y. NORDEROJ
VI JOLADOE WILSTGYSE.Y SOR  WNNL
T BN DSEONHN BRNAY TLY
D C GTE REAN IT' TEA AS OSITER
PSWNHOE,AT J M YO WAIHA IEIN ADE
SSHETNDNCO T'STA B  WILHAG- IUTA
ED SD.  ISSES NUSATHSU LIL ID T
TNTGLL IHEDEELFBUH  IOKOM SAV TT
THLIFERENA
S.D K B F  LOR  B
E P S STSTAONLIAY AS  W. TE B
HEALN  HTSE.  W TTADEBOM CN
THEAT  PNEIMUR B T PEERO A DRT.I
ODETOM
F B AOSU.XT JIGHEOWWAFE
BOOW SOWPESH  TGTLD
K OUCGOM.E
ELDNIYHI MU RFRERROAS A
E SSIS. TONGE OER T